يعود نفوذ روسيا في افريقيا الى فتره
العهد السوفيتي وان لم يكن وجود السوفييت
كبيرا في افريقيا حتى حركات التحرر من
الاستعمار عند بدايه تلك الحركات لجا
الاتحاد السوفيتي الى دعمها سواء عبر
مستشارين او التدريب او توريد السلاح
لمحاربه النفوذ الغربي الاستعماري
والامبرياليه كما كان السوفييت والمعسكر
الشيوعي يصفونها في ذلك الوقت
بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي تضائل النفوذ
الى ان عادت روسيا باستراتيجيات جديده في
عهد بوتين منها اقتصادي واخرى غير تقليديه
كاستخدام ميليشيا فاجنر حيث اتهمت روسيا
بتسخير المجموعه لدعم ديكتاتوريات او قوى
معارضه في القاره
يسمح الاسلوب غير التقليدي في استخدام
الميليشيات للدول بدل الجيوش بالتنصر من
المسؤوليه المباشره في الاحداث وعدم ربطها
مباشره بالدوله ويخفف من ضغط الراي العام
الداخلي حيث لا يوضع ابناء الجيش النظامي
في مواجهات خارجيه مباشره
هذه هي خريطه للنفوذ الروسيه عبر استخدام
ميليشيا زاجنر في القاره
يعتمد النفوذ على مزيج من الاليات مقسم
الى درجات حسب وثيقه سابقه نسبت لفاجنر
وسربت الى الاعلام الدرجه واحد مثلث الحد
الادنى من التعاون في حين مثلت ادرجه خمسه
الحد الاعلى في ذلك الوقت دعونا نستعرض
مثالين يختصران اشكال الدعم
لايفاجنر في بسط النفوذ الروسي في افريقيا
في ليبيا شاركت ميليشيات في دعم خليفه
حفتر ضد حكومه الوفاق الوطني والهجومي على
طرابلس لكنها في الوقت نفسه كانت توجد
قربه حقلين مهمين للغاز في البلاد وذلك
لحمايتهم ويقع الحقلان ضمن نفوذ حفتر وهما
الوفاء والفارغ
حيث اشارت دراسات الى ان ليبيا لم تتمكن
من الاستفاده من تصدير الغاز الى اوروبا
لتعويض نقص الغاز الروسي عند حدوث ازمه
الطاقه اثر الحرب في اوكرانيا وعزت السبب
الى وجود فاغنر قرب الحقلين وتحكمي
المجموعه بهما او عبر حلفاء لها في الداخل
الليبي الامر الذي لعب لصالح روسيا في
ازمه الغازي الاوروبيه
في افريقيا الوسطى دخلت المجموعه بطلب من
الرئيس تواديرا لتوفير حمايه له بعد
محاوله الانقلاب ولتدريب الجيش في المقابل
وضعت يدها على موارد طبيعيه في البلاد
كمناجم يذهب
هذا جزء من عمليات فاغنر في افريقيا قبل
تمردها على الكرملين لكن التساؤل يبقى عن
كيفيه عمل النفوذ الروسي والياته في مرحله
ما بعد فاجنر وكيف ستتغير استراتيجيه
روسيا في القاره لاحقا